the new biography Tiger Woods uncovers
new information about his life and
career it's published by Simon &
Schuster a division of CBS the
co-authors investigative journalist
Armand Kitaen and Sports Illustrated
writer Jeff Benedict did more than 400
interviews with people close to woods
good morning morning morning quite a
book congratulations to both of you
Armand few people go by one name like
Tiger does one of the greatest athletes
ever on the planet transformed the golf
game what did you seek to learn about
him well we tried to understand him sort
of the the predominant question for both
Jeff and I was who is Tiger Woods and to
understand Tiger you really have to go
back to the beginning and really to his
grandparents on his father's side under
ill side and that was that was really
our mission is to take the whole arc of
his life there had been a number of
books written about tiger but they were
all kind of segmented into certain parts
of his life Jeff and I tried to do this
360 degree view of as you said Nora
probably one of the greatest athletes
ever to walk the face of the earth
and when you start with that question
who is Tiger Woods the other question is
the price of fame and the price of
genius and that was really what drove us
so tell us about his grandparents and
his parents well Earl and Tita I mean
they're they're a pair for both good and
bad start with as a team right elder on
one side is the e4 Earl on the other
side is the K for K tilde and literally
surrounded by his parents for good and
bad from birth some would argue may be
imprisoned by his parents in some ways
his mom was the ultimate tiger mom dad
behind him in the Gulf mm-hm but you
know what was so interesting to me is
because I was very judgmental about
Tiger Woods I have to say I saw him as a
cheater cheater pumpkin eater I met Elin
a couple of times thought she was lovely
could never understand it and I just
thought you know just he to me was not
likable not approachable but I read this
book and my heart actually changed and I
never thought I would say that because
you really put in context guys what
Oprah has said in her 60 minutes because
it's not what what are you doing it's
what happened to you and let's start
with his parents you tell a great story
from the time that he was in
chair his dad is hitting the ball
hitting the ball she's feeding him and
just how that imprinted on his mind and
when Nora says ultimate Tiger mom his
mom was the one who has really had had
the killing machine for him Jeff yeah
and she she came comes to America
doesn't speak much in the way of English
she doesn't know anything about American
culture she marries a man who was
married when he married her and it was
also very unfaithful it was very
insightful and so from the very
beginning she sort of swept into this
into this situation in a relationship
and in a country that's very foreign to
her and then she has one child and when
she has a child it happens right when
her her husband is taking up the sport
of golf and he's basically living in the
garage when he's not at work no and the
baby starts coming in and sitting in the
highchair and watching his dad hit golf
balls and so for her to have time with
her son she sits next to the night chair
and in between hits puts food in his
mouth you know Gerber baby food or
whatever it is and to me that if you
look at formation of this young man it
all starts right there
if you right Tigers inability to show
gratitude apologize or express
appreciation was rooted in this
upbringing yeah his mother pampered him
like a prince his father rarely uttered
the words thank you
or I'm sorry yeah and so there's two
things there one is Earl is a guy I
think who felt like they were entitled
when he recognized that his son had a
talent that no one else had I mean there
were certain things about Tiger that he
just had and then there were other parts
of him that I think were taught to him
by the way he was raised but there's no
question he had talent that was I think
god-given I mean he was born with
certain abilities that were honed by the
way he was raised and but once they got
out on the circuit as a junior golfer
and they're you know the equivalent of
Little League and peewee football for
him was golf tournaments where he's
crushing everyone and his dad just
expected that when they went to people's
homes or the tournaments they were the
best and they should be treated that way
yeah so he didn't see thank you we
appreciate you he never saw that his dad
predicted at a very early age that he
would be the greatest
ever play the game and chosen one that
he was a chilly he even used a frozen
engine that on your shoulders growing up
but the way that he treated him he was
very disparaging of him he would put him
down and they had a code word between
them that if it got too much he was
supposed to say enough and you never
said ever said it I think that's how bad
it got that says a lot actually about
that relationship is interesting because
last year Tiger wrote his own book and
he talked about that language that his
father used which as a parent as I have
two sons and two daughters when I read
that language the first thing I thought
was wow I can't imagine speaking that
way to one of my children and expecting
that that's going to make them do better
but Tiger looks back and reflects on
that now and says it helped make him who
he is on the golf course that's one of
the reasons he's so hard to beat this is
a guy who this is a guy who at his peak
journalists who t lee complained about
was remote was untouchable and
accessible has that changed yes it has
change and I think it changed last year
about this time when he found himself on
the side of the road in Florida with a
one hell of a rock star cocktail of
opioids in his system and I think that
was the that was the bottom that for
Tiger and because of his kids and
because he's now healthy for the first
time in five years but he's spiritually
healthy and emotionally healthy for the
first time I think in his life what why
what's what's I think because he I think
what happened in that Florida Road was a
complete wake-up call for him and I
think now he sees his children he does
not want to have the life that he had
with his parents for his kids and you
say what did you learn about whether
he's used performance-enhancing drugs
well there's a chapter called miracle
workers that I worked on a long time on
and it has the most definitive statement
to date the most authoritative statement
to date from mark Lindsay who is Tigers
chiropractor who says and marks had his
hands on Olympic athletes all around the
world and says he does not believe the
tiger used performance-enhancing drugs
Oh perfect timing you know I doubt Tiger
would read this book but he should it
would be very I think helpful and
enlightening even to him I think it was
really very very very well done
and just in time for the Masters Armen
Kitaen and Jeff Benedict who thank you
Tiger Woods goes on sale tomorrow
wherever you like to buy your books